we are now going to cover the famous or
perhaps infamous potato problem from the
2017 AP calculus exam at time T equals
zero a boiled potato is taken from a pot
on a stove and left to cool in a kitchen
the internal temperature of the potato
is 91 degrees Celsius at time T equals
zero and the internal temperature of the
potato is greater than 27 degrees for
all times T greater than zero I would
guess that the ambient room temperature
is 27 degrees Celsius and so that's why
the temperature would approach this but
it will always stay a little bit greater
than that as T gets larger and larger
the internal temperature of the potato
at time T at time T minutes can be
modeled by the function H that satisfies
the differential equation D H DT the
derivative of our internal temperature
with respect to time is equal to
negative 1/4 times R the difference
between our internal temperature and the
ambient room temperature where H of T is
measured in degrees Celsius and H of 0
is equal to 91 so before I even read
Part A let's just make sense of what
this differential equation is telling us
so let's see if it's consistent with our
intuition so let me draw some axes here
so this is my y-axis so that is my
y-axis and this right over here is my t
axis now if the ambient room temperature
is 27 degrees Celsius I'll just draw
there that's what the room temperature
is doing and so we know at T equals 0
our potato is at 91 degrees so see
that's 27 91 might be right over there
91 this is all in degrees Celsius and
what you would expect intuitively is
that it would start to cool and when its
temperature when there's a big
difference between the potato in the
room maybe its rate of change is steeper
than when there's a little difference so
it would you would expect the graph to
look something like this so you would
expect it to look something like this
and then asymptotes towards a
temperature of 27
degrees Celsius so this is what you
would expect to see and this
differential equation is consistent with
that where the rate of change notice
this is for all T greater than zero this
is going to be a negative value because
our potato is greater than 27 for T
greater than zero so this part here is
going to be positive but then you
multiply positive times negative 1/4
you're constantly going to have a
negative rate of change which makes
sense the potato is cooling down and it
also makes sense that your rate of
change is proportional to the difference
between the temperature of the potato
and the ambient room temperature well
there's a big difference you expect a
steeper rate of change but then when
there's less of a difference the rate of
change you could imagine becomes less
and less and less negative as we asked
them to towards the ambient temperature
so with this out of the way now let's
tackle part a write an equation for the
line tangent to the graph of H at T
equals 0 use this equation to
approximate the internal temperature of
the potato at time T equals 3 so what
are we going to do well we're going to
think about what's going on at time T
equals 0 right over here we want the
equation of the tangent line which might
look something like this at T equals 0
so this thing would be of the form Y is
equal to the slope of the equation of
the tangent line well it would be the
derivative of our function at that point
so dhdt times T plus our y-intercept
where does it intersect the y axis here
well when T is equal to 0 the value the
value of this equation is going to be 91
because it intersects our graph right at
that point that point 0 comma 91 plus 91
so what is our derivative of H with
respect to T at time T equals zero right
at this point right over here well we
just have to look at this you could also
write this as H prime of T right over
here so if we want to think about H
prime
of zero that's going to be equal to
negative one-fourth times H of zero
minus 27 what is our initial temperature
minus 27 this is of course 91 degrees
they tell us that multiple times we've
even drawn it a few times
91 minus 27 is 64 64 times negative 1/4
is equal to negative 16 so this is
negative 16 right over here so just like
that we have the equation for the line
tangent to the graph of H at T is equal
to 0 I'll write it one more time it is a
mini drumrolls here Y is equal to
negative 16 T plus 91 that's the
equation of that tangent line right over
there and then they say we want to use
this equation to approximate the
internal temperature of the potato at
time T equals 3 so let's say that this
is time T equals 3 right over here we
want to approximate the temperature that
this model describes right over here but
we're going to do it using the line so
we're going to evaluate the line at T
equals 3 so then we would get let's see
negative 16 times 3 plus 91 is equal to
this is negative 48 plus 91 is equal to
what is that 43 so this is equal to 43
degrees Celsius so this right over here
is the equation for the line tangent to
the graph of H at T is equal to 0 and
this right over here is our
approximation using that equation of the
tangent line of the internal temperature
of the potato at time T is equal to 3